one two three oh [ __ ] it's our film
ladies exciting stuff feels a little
different around here and we got a few
men in the gym finally all right don't
distract and they have work to do my
costume still smells like beer and
racism
was I supposed to wash these you have a
good break yeah
just divorced it's complicated
usually you do a lot better job and keep
your weird friendship stuff out of the
ring just so you can keep out of it
you're on that show right glow Wilfred
Queen it's a wrestling show I'm not the
only offensive character everyone's
offensive we have fans I mean the girls
get letters there's weirdos waiting
outside wait
you're my favorite I can see that we're
gonna be canceled I can't believe this
I think this mania has something to do
with me that is how this business works
it shouldn't be that way they gave a
men's wrestling show our slot so you
just let them do whatever they want
[ __ ] now what are we gonna do about it I
say we do whatever the hell we want to
do except the weirdos free and see what
happens
you wanna be respected you gotta make
yourself useful I know it I'm worse and
I'm not apologizing to anyone
everything is gonna be hard I forgot to
pick up my son at daycare today I don't
want to make this show that
who's ready to do this but I know this
is gonna be hard
but I believe in miracles and we are
going to make this miracle happen we are
the gorgeous ladies
you want to wrestle with mommy so you're
older you can talk about it with your
stairs
[Music]